we looked at diagrams right and we left
that there were two main categories of
diagrams that we can use to represent
sets okay the first one you've been very
familiar with what's it called a Venn
diagram and what does it look like what
is it like it looks like circles very
good that's right so you had something
like this classic Venn diagram after we
looked at pen diagrams we then looked at
saying well you know you don't have to
arrange it like this all you need is to
have four separate regions that can
represent the same thing right so what
was the other kind of diagram good good
it starts the same way with this you
know outer sort of rectangle right it
represents everything but then we broke
it up like this we said look you can
just do four that way that's all you
have to do and just to describe what's
what we added these little bits on the
sides I can't wear my tailor a and not
anything B and not B and then you've got
represented exactly the same information
okay so we looked at different kinds of
diagrams today we're going to look at
different kinds of diagrams for
different numbers of sets okay because
look at these both of these despite
their differences same number sets how
many just two
so let's where we go to study this well
let's wrap it up let's ramp it up okay
so if I wanted to say take a Venn
diagram and represent not there's a and
B but a B and C what would it look like
now it sort of makes sense should I look
I have two circles here I'll just do
three circles no problem so let's draw
this together okay you got your
Universal set out here okay and you want
to draw some nice neat circles sweet
there you go now before we move off this
let's think of an example we have
and a and a B before from memory I think
we said a were the even numbers said
right then we said B were the multiples
of three okay
multiples of three okay now what should
we pick is our third set C I suppose you
could go multiples of two three four but
was a bit boring for was a bit boring
because it's kind of so overlapping with
this one I'm just going to ditch it
let's go up to five multiples of five
okay now I think we went and defined the
universal set as numbers under 30 all
right let's say I give it enough numbers
for this let's go a up here B over here
C here
okay now because there's this additional
area in overlap okay just be careful but
draw yourself a new diagram and let's
put in let's put in all the numbers from
1 to 30 obviously we're very very
similar to your previous diagram right
well this is gonna be a little more
detail to it so I'll give you one or two
minutes to catch that up okay okay now
just like before okay
we saw the wing you put it together with
just a be just a in B different areas
had different attributes about them okay
so for instance if you have a look in
here this is 10 and 20 obviously this is
10 and 20 why it's going to be now
number one you've got to be multiples of
two and five so that makes you multiples
of ten if you think of prime
factorization ah but it's not just
multiples of two and five it's only the
ones that not every third one you get 30
and 60 and 90 120 here if I kept going
right and then you can see this other
patterns we should recognize before look
you're going to get multiples of 15 in
here because it's 3s 500 no problem okay
but then you think about this we have
this Carol diagram for two sets and that
works pretty happily
right but if you wanted to replicate
this
yes this three sets on the coward I
agree
well you'd kind of need it like you got
one dimension two dimensions you have
three dimensions you'd have to come off
the board
wouldn't you or do you
so here's Mike our diagram over here
maybe you want to start throwing one as
well it'll need to be big enough to fit
30 numbers in it okay how can we modify
this to set our diagram to be able to
account for three sets
no yeah so I could do let's think about
this for a second how about doing it
this way this is this is three okay now
this is a it's not a bad suggestion
because it does add in more regions
which is what I need okay but there's a
problem this before we move on to a
different a new idea
can anyone see why there's actually a
problem with this like if each one of
those was a region okay now this is
racing we're gonna come back to this
idea but it is critical right so far
this way in your head this is a good
idea but it does break down on it by the
way it max would you this all the time
okay
we think of ideas we just just try it
what do you got to lose right nothing
but then we work out internal
inconsistencies we're gonna come to this
later when we look it up the next topic
man there okay
so count about you know one section here
or region two three four five six seven
eight
by the way I didn't do that order
randomly I wonder if he could work out
how I did that or not but fair enough
I have eight regions and here I got line
this clearly a done okay so I can't do
it this way it was a good idea but does
there have any other suggestions
yeah you're just yours way in a minute
that's fine no problem it's not easy
yeah do you want a four by two okay so
I could do it like this if I did three
big oh cool I've got eight that's good
okay so you're thinking maybe if I have
if I call these well if I go like so
okay and then so I go B and not B is
that okay yeah so we suggest see how you
see and not see here hmm all right now
see this is this is better and now it's
got the right number of spots but it's
problematic because I'm missing some
areas for instance let's think about 30
we would 30 go in this diagram I need it
to be a and B and C and there isn't like
it's a and B is saying see but a B and C
never overlap okay so this is also a
good idea but we still want with a
problem one more I know
so Jimmy where do you think you're
putting it oh you mean like this oh you
mean like you mean like that you mean
seem not see here but what I have
exactly the same yeah one more okay okay
sure okay some of these now like that
you mean okay now this is interesting
this is interesting okay is this gonna
work out my question before was where do
I put 13 right we're done for 30 when I
put I want a and B and C all together
can I do it
I still can't and I also have these
extra regions right okay now that's
that's cause for minute
because we could play this game for a
long time right let me show you how we
did it with the Venn diagram because
maybe this will make sense right you can
see that this diagram is just this
diagram plus another circle okay but
where we place the circle is critical
for instance I couldn't replace the
circle here can you see that that's a
good place to put the third circle why
it doesn't overlap with B that's my
problem so I only add I don't add enough
through extra regions but instead we
chose footsie here it overlaps with all
of them
so what I need to do is modify this
diagram so see overlaps with all before
well that's not bad is it
how many regions have I got one two
three four five six seven eight
check if I call this inside inside C and
if I call the outside not C okay so we
were to put 30 now 30 right I'll put
there what it's a and B and C all at the
same time so C is inside the square and
not C is outside the square okay sure
now let's replay this okay where can I
put all of my numbers let's think about
these numbers out here these guys these
are they all private yeah they're all
private okay
where'd all the primes go they should be
in the universal set not a and not B and
not C where is that that's bottom right
good so all of my Prime's going here 1 7
11 13 this is out of order
that's okay we got the moment okay does
that make sense let's keep going look at
this one what's this reading this is
and B but not C a and B but not C that's
these guys right the multiples of six
except the I'm going to get rid of these
own red numbers don't think they're
confusing I'm sorry
cuz they are not part of this that was
me counting up how many regions I had
that's better okay so a and B but not C
that's these multiples 612 okay and you
can go from there let's let's just
finish it off what am I gonna have yeah
this is C a and C and C but not be so
I've got 10 and 20 in there okay I'm
gonna have 15 where's that that's going
to be B and C B and C but not a yeah
that'll be 50 what's this one here this
is only C naught a naught B that makes
it 5 and 25 so look see there's my
square C and it's got all of the
multiples of 5 just like you'd expect
okay I've got two regions left which
one's this be
it's only been only B so that should be
three 92127 and this one over here
should be only a yes two four eight 14
16 22 26 28 and you can go and count to
make sure we haven't missed any okay so
that's pretty cool right
I quite like that